I have covered many lore-lacking enemies
on this channel from Lonely NPCs like
the Raven Mountain assassin to Mobs with
no in-game name like the lookout stones
but this video's subject blows them all
out of the water both in mystery and in
the amount of hate it gets from players
it's not the revenants although they are
a fellow Contender for most hated Enemy
No this orb of pain is likely not even
registered as a distinct foe by most
players in this video I want to explore
the lightning spheres found in the
chauffeur River and the consecrated snow
field players know these electric
bubbles to be mercilessly strong
especially when met early in a first
playthrough after you elevate her down
to the river for the first time but
these aren't some devilishly strong
sorcery or incantation cooked up by the
ancestral followers they are an enemy in
their own right and they even have a
proper name at least I think they do so
join me in this video as we explore the
lore and intricacies of the Wisps of the
lanes between and as we get going feel
free to subscribe since most of you
watching the video probably haven't as I
said we find them in the chauffeur River
and the consecrated snow field so these
balls of blue are only found near
ancestral followers we read from the
ancestral follower ashes that they are a
horned folk who issue letters and metal
working the ancestral followers reject
modernity and technology and they prefer
everything natural which means they
wouldn't be too interested in this
video's sponsor manscape but that
doesn't mean you have to be in the same
boat after all you're watching this
video on some device so you can't hate
metalworking all that much manscaped is
a global provider of Men's Grooming and
hygiene products most of you watching my
channel are apparently men and we all
know Gamers have quite the stereotype of
uncleanliness to break though hair is
hair so if you're a woman watching and
looking for a hair trimmer this should
work for you as well I recently received
the lawnmower TM 4.0 for manscaped and I
gotta say it is a fine trimmer suitable
for all kinds of body hair from beard to
below you can get the lawnmower in the
perfect package 4.0 which comes with a
few other hygienic products too right
now you can get a great 20 discount free
international shipping and two extra
free gifts I know free wow by going to
this link and or using my promo code add
Luigi check it out in the description
below back on topic these fears are
related to the followers in some way
which is an easy enough conjecture based
on their placement now let's get into
some more substance reading from The
Game's internal file names we could call
these little orbs wisps as I did in the
intro now plenty of internal file names
would make poorer actual enemy titles
after all we have examples like Chimera
JS base type or even dead Miner or
digging flamethrower underscore back
luggage rare Stone but wisp seems like a
thematically fine enough name to me if
it's the enemy and it's not unwieldy and
filled with underscores and it will work
as a point of lore speculation so I'm
going to decree that Wisp as a name for
this enemy gets a mad Luigi stamp of
approval wisp is also evocative for our
lore hunting ends as you will see
throughout this video the Spheres have
association with the ancestral followers
a kind of people of the past of the
lands between and the name wisp can
further this relation because of the
words real world connection to Folklore
and old myth the word wisp has a few
definitions and histories one says it is
an immeasurable indefinable essence of
life soul with a further description
adding this context another traditional
answer to the question of what makes us
so different popular for Millennia has
been that humans have a non-physical
Soul when that inhabits the body but is
distinct from it and ethereal ghostly
wisp that floats free at death to enjoy
an afterlife which may include reunion
with other souls or perhaps a new body
to inhabit by the end of the video I
will conclude that the Wisps are likely
something like this an aspect of the
life and death cycle of the ancestrals
but there are still more definitions
that need to be mentioned a whisk can
also be a small bundle like a wisp of
hair or of Twigs used as a makeshift
torch and this leads to the other
prominent candidate maybe wisp is in
reference to the Latin ignis fatus more
commonly called the will of the Wisp or
simply willow wisp you can find many
different descriptions of a Willow the
Wisp but most will include that it is
some ethereal light which Travelers may
see at night perhaps over a bog or Marsh
and it often leads them astray forever
Out Of Reach there are some Modern
scientific reasonings for what may cause
these lights bioluminescence and such
but in Antiquity they were attributed to
ghosts gnomes fairies or other Spirits
so this definition also works for the
context of the orbs in the lands between
it even provides a Justified
circumstance for the ancestral followers
being kind of a people of antiquity to
call the orbs wisps going further into
the fairy aspect of the will of the
Wisps Welsh folklore calls the Wisp
fairy fire that is held by a puka which
is the pronunciation according to a
Welsh short film a puka is a small
Goblin like Berry that mischievously
leads lone Travelers off the beaten path
though that description is from
Wikipedia so take it with a grain of
salt and something I somehow managed to
not include in the original version of
my script shofra is an Irish word which
means fairy which definitely adds to the
fairy connection here especially because
I don't think chauffeur River has any
better candidate for a fairy than the
Wisps there's also Scottish folklore
which sometimes regards the lights as
quote Omens of death or the ghosts of
once living human beings while the Wisps
in game don't really lead us far astray
they do present themselves as something
interesting and odd to check out only to
strike at us with their deadly lightning
after luring Us in so it fits the bill a
bit and as I said before I think they
are a part of the ancestral Life Death
cycle so that would seem up with the
Scottish view as ghosts of the dead here
in my home of the United States
apparently another term that some
folklorists use for the will of the
Wisps is simply orbs so one more
connection to boot for the orbs of the
lanes between and with all that
nomenclature knowledge in mind let's
look more closely in game at the Wisps
themselves the Spheres are so ephemeral
and transitory that learning anything
about them is pretty hard to do by just
playing the game after all we had to
look at internal file names to get even
a name now I am not a hacker or even a
very good modder of games so I had to
reach out to fellow YouTuber pentagona
for this one if you haven't seen their
balls vs bosses videos go check them out
they're a lot of great fun pentagona
confirmed to me that the Wisps are not
some spell or like kinded thing they are
in fact classified as enemies they have
their own AI they have 187 base HP they
are simply untargetable and invincible
so we can't interact with them like
normal enemies we can only brace their
attacks and try to survive or Dodge the
five or six surges of lightning they
emit before disappearing the other day I
did a live stream of some lore research
and some viewers were trying to guess
what sound is similar to the sound the
Wisp makes when it disappears
options included the sound of popping a
rune
the sound of the teardrop scarabs
disappearing
or the sound of casting Glenstone pebble
there's not too much that comes to mind
for the Scarab connections other than
there being quite a few scarabs around
the chauffeur River and the consecrated
snow field where we find the Wisps
because I don't see much of a connection
here let me know if you think there's a
Scarab connection I'm missing if we do
believe that the Wisps sound like the
Glenstone sorcery then that would
provide a connection between Leonia and
the underground which may be furthered
by the connection of ice magic we can
find ice and lightning magic in the
Dragon King Soldier near the Wisps and
more dragonkins show up in the snow in
the form of spirits plus we know that
further ice magic may be connected to
Ronnie and those who served her
according to IceBear there is more to be
said about the possible connection
between the hernia and the underground
cities but I think that would be delving
more into Knox territory than ancestral
follower and I think the Wisps are more
creatures of the latter however I now
see that my next Point could kind of be
taken either way so who knows maybe I'm
wrong in that account if we return to
our last similar sound candidate to the
Wisps the Golden Rule phones we get to
see another example of the game's very
real dichotomy of gold and silver
all of the golden ruins state that they
are Grace that dwells within the
inhabitants of the lands between the
lingering residue of gold the golden
runes are unsurprisingly part of the
overall setup of the herd tree its Grace
and the golden order they also have a
bit of visual similarity with the Wisps
having a center sphere surrounded by a
more ethereal outer shell kind of like
the nucleus of an atom and a
circumscribing electron cloud we could
think of the golden runes as the order
counterpart to the Wisps they have a
similar design and may be sound one is
gold and of the archery the other is
blue white evocative of silver and of
the underground as I said the wists are
found underground and in the consecrated
snow field I'm pretty sure those are
their only locations but I said
something similar in my Lookout Stone
video and was wrong so please let me
know in the comments if there are any
other instances of these Wisps in the
world the underground is obviously
antithetical to the Earth tree the
tree's light does not reach underground
and it is also the land of the Knox
enemies of the greater will and its
order the consecrated snow field is
above ground but it is also a secret
area that leads up to the Hallock tree
the embodiment of Nicola's rejection of
the order and archery plus due to the
strong snow the air tree's light doesn't
reach the snow field the many wisps we
find here can only exist because there
is a blanket of cover from the earth
tree or at least it seems that way to me
this could explain why there aren't any
wisps and liernia with the ancestral
followers there the light of the earth
tree makes it impossible now it might
not be that the Wisps serve the exact
same role for the anti-urgury team as
the golden ruins do for the ER tree but
we can still note some of the
similarities they have being kind of
gold silver counterparts with the
meaning from the name Wisp and the
possible connection to the runes our
lightning orbs could exist as part of
the spirit circle of the ancestral
followers after all we know the
followers have their own experience of
death and rebirth the remembrance of the
Regal ancestor notes that ancestral
Spirits exist as a phenomenon beyond the
purview of the archery life Sprouts from
Death as it does from birth such is the
way of the living
there is also the ancestral spirit's
horn which says a number of new growths
Bud from the antler-like horns of the
Fallen King each glowing with light thus
does New Life grow from death and from
Death one obtains power The ancestral
Society shuns metalworking and the
modern world it rejects the Earth tree
and holds on to its old practices of
death and new life we see in the wing
Great Horn tell of envoy's wings made to
reap the lives of beings which
experience no sprouting and its unique
skill Soul Stifler shows off the power
they are in touch with whereby they can
generate a soul-saphene miasma with this
deep connection to life and death so far
as to generate a unique power plus the
separation from the earth tree I think
it's no big leap to connect the Wisps
somewhere in this equation in terms of
unique power and anti-order sentiment we
find the Wisps fitting with the rest of
the ancestral Faith Like These in a pot
as we begin to wrap up the theory I
could also note the white trees of the
inside specials forests which are also
found in the consecrated snow fields
surrounded by red leaves or what looks
like leaves this was immediately
evocative to me of the Weir woods from
Game of Thrones but as I myself have not
done a deep dive into the ancestral
followers I don't know what strong
connections are to be made of the trees
broken white and without tops if you
have ideas please leave a comment about
what you think the Wisps and their
volatile attacks make for a frightening
lightning enemy that haunts many a
player especially since their first
encounter is likely to be early when
exploring Chopra for the first time and
not just domineering they are also
enigmatic with no health bar item drop
no chance to even be attacked all on top
of their disappearing act once they emit
their bolts given the history of their
wispy name it's not surprising that they
occupy a fuzzy space getting compared to
an item in the golden ruins despite
being classified as an enemy they are
one of the most unique entities in the
game and that makes battening down what
they are so much harder I feel strongly
that they are part of the spirit system
of the ancestrals and I hope I have made
my case well maybe there are some form
in between death and New Life perhaps
representing the power that comes from
Death as referenced by The ancestral
spirit's horn they are clearly powerful
but they are also transient fading as
soon as they attack like a honeybee and
it's one sting doomed to disappear if
they wish to use their power
I wasn't able to draw as distinct
conclusions about the Wisps as I did
with the lookout stones but hey we do
have a feasible name to call them now at
least as things are left more open-ended
feel free to stay in the comments your
thoughts and theories about these orbs
of electricity and if you've enjoyed the
video feel free to subscribe or support
my work on patreon shout out to my
patrons who are already doing so I also
made a Discord so join that for
discussions on Eldon ring it's lore and
other games and topics if that suits
your fancy and thanks for watching I
really hope you enjoyed the video and
hopefully I will see you soon again to
talk more about lore and maybe about DLC
we'll see thanks again peace